[Musique]
une fois pour le nord le nord mon
terroir la martinique mon pays c'est le
titre de cet ouvrage qui vient de sortir
bonjour madeleine de grandmaison bonjour
en ciel tombe on jouera aux auditeurs et
auditrices anciens élus d'ajouts pas
bouillon du conseil régional député
européen président de l'office de l'eau
du comité martiniquais du tourisme une
belle vie politique que vous avez eu
envie madeleine de grandmaison de
résumer à travers livres ou plutôt une
partie de cette vie politique
oui je me suis attardé sur tout ce qui
concerne le nord de la martinique est à
mon sens nous sommes un peu farfelu en
parlant de grand nord nous sommes une
île 2000 80 kilomètres carrés les lignes
à l'est mais je ne vois pas quel grand
lyon ont peu avant peut avoir un cap et
c'est pour ça que dans des tons qu'angie
travailler sur le pays d'accueil j'ai
parlé de dupes les noms le cap nord le
cap plein nord plein nord mais comme
dans l'homme au moins ça passe pas dans
ça alors cette action politique que vous
avez menées dans le nord il ya eu
convergence il ya eu le pays d'accueil
touristique avec huit communes une
première question madeleine de
grandmaison le nord comme un scoop pour
vous avais attention le nom c'est le n'y
a pas de y'a pas de commencer un rang
qu'elle en tel endroit ou tel endroit
par contre je leur ai tous lus tournant
parfois même par contre quand j'ai
défini le pays d'accueil touristique et
que j'ai regroupé huit communes partant
du morne-rouge arrivant à grand rivière
et est traversant pour le prêcheur c'est
un territoire absolument défini
naturellement et par des éléments
naturels
mer montagne et une cohérence depuis la
colonisation
voyez vous c'est simplement ceux de
terrain qui va de marigot au au prêcheur
en passant par le mont rose rouge
ça peut paraître un petit peu traficoter
non parce qu'à l'époque où précisément
ce territoire a été défini par
l'histoire ont marché à travers la forêt
ont marché à travers les chemins en fait
marcher à travers les traces maintenant
on a fait des routes par conséquent
quand j'arrive au poteau c'est à dire à
l'entrée d'ajouts pas bouillon si
j'avais un moment de lobbying pour
remonter si j'arrive on l'aurait il me
faut remonter ça ne se faisait pas
le temps sa soeur traversait le pays à
cheval à pied à travers la forêt donc il
y avait une cohérence mais cette partie
que j'ai individualisé a été marquée par
l'éruption de la montagne pelée
l'éruption de 1930 par dans les options
du 30 août 1902 a des limites et de
limiter les auteurs du lorrain a touché
ajoupa bouillon a touché tous ceux qui
descendent vers basse-pointe hévéa
marcoux bas jusqu'au moins cher par
conséquent la en un territoire qui est
pratiquement défini naturellement bordée
par la mental que les parlements de
jacob
par conséquent nous avons là une terre
une terre pays dans le sens actuel du
terme
un pays c'est à dire aux fragments de
territoire bien défini et c'est un peu
le territoire de convergence alors
convergence cette action d'envergure qui
conte qui consistait à animer cette
partie de l'île on va pas refaire
l'historique de toutes ses actions en un
constat l'oeil nord de l'île dispose
d'atouts considérables plus vives de la
nature dit vous peut vivre de son
environnement et vous nous avez démontré
qu'on pouvait initiés quelque chose ce
que vous avez fait oui et convergence
n'est pas isolé c'est le troisième axe
d'un plan de développement coordonné
qu'on peut entendre la culture
convergence on représente la culture
il n'y a pas de développement sans socle
culturel parce que c'est ça qui permet
de faire peuple c'est ça qui permettent
d'identifier des gens et de faire vivre
en paix en quelque sorte un territoire
donc il y avait la culture avec
convergence la formation avec un centre
de formation que nous avons créé et puis
l'exploitation des sites naturels ce
bambin cause la falaise les ombrages et
tout le reste place qu'à la leur et
baume & mercier n'a peur du rugby le
congo est le chanteur qui la faute à
quoi
un bain il n'y a pas de faute à chercher
il faut chercher une volonté il faut
chercher un saisissement des choses et
de faire avancer
et là ça assise une absence de volonté
je ne peux pas être tout le monde et il
faut que les choses soient prises en
relais par l'esl et décisionnel par les
parts par les politiques les gens du
territoire qui ici s'il voit que ça peut
servir il faut avancer
je n'incrimine personne joueur est ce
que nous avons
existe aujourd'hui tout ce que nous
avons vécu là perdure personnes leur
continue ce que quelqu'un a commencé ici
c'est ça le problème c'est ça le
problème c'est parce que les cerveaux du
nord sont partis ailleurs
ah non pas du tout le cerveau de
personnes a pris le relais qui avait si
les gens n'ont pas pris le rôle est
d'abord il faut de l'été or il faut
analyser profondément c'est pas ça
seulement qu'on n'a pas pris l'eau je ne
viens pas ici venir faire de la
polémique et montrer des choses qui ont
été défaites et démonté pendant 13 ans
lorsque vous pouvez par exemple
marcellin nadeau qui a engendré un vil
du prêcheur vais vous applaudissez quoi
marcellin nadeau m a pris le relais sous
son territoire il a créé et a créé des
jardins il a incité la population à
faire des choses c'est ça qu'il aurait
fallu et à plus grande échelle encore
chaque oeuf pourtant sa pierre pour
pouvez vous développer le territoire
il ne faut pas qu'un territoire par s
est la propriété de quelques hauts
absolument le fait de quelqu'un il faut
que ce soit une oeuvre commune et c'est
pour ça que j'ai bien dit dans l'oise
que vous que vous citez que l'heure
n'est pas une île dans la martinique
le nord doit faire partie d'un projet
global et sans projet global justement
demande de la volonté politique
allongé et non non non non ça demande de
la volonté politique et sa demande
l'unité l'unité peut pas cacher que
voient dans chaque un concurrent mais
voilà le monde lève on voulait freiner
trop fort moi je suis une personne ayant
tu le sais étaient de flop et si tu
comptes tu m'as dit des choses vont
mieux a dit des choses qui peut m'amener
à apparaître soir qui qu'untel ou untel
je suis obligé de parler très fort vous
faire autant mais restait à écouter le
soc 2 kg rouler à cet ouvrage alors vous
avez question pour sonner comme une
ébauche de programme à l'échelle du
continent
cet ouvrage est à fixer dans les fruits
les expériences que j'ai pu mener qui
ont donné des résultats parce que dans
le fond aux ornaisons mois il est passé
jusqu'à trente mille personnes par an il
est passé après ça a décliné mais il est
passé juste à trente mille personnes par
an j'ai sorti des de la végétation
une ruine une win une industrielle qui
maintenant se trouve dans le roi sens
mans de tout ce qu'il y a eu comme comme
habitation et en plus nous avons eu des
restaurants vous allez voir dans cet
ouvrage à 25 qui ont profité précisément
pour montrer tout ce que le témoin
pouvait produire et aliments et est
donné comme comme culture culinaire vous
apprendrez la culture on voit que vous
parlez très très fort et produire ma
question est ce que c'est aussi une
ébauche de programme politique mais non
c'est une 7e carrare cahier de
suggestions
les gens qui devaient faire dans la
politique et développer le nord peuvent
aller si on retrouve et je vais vous
dire une chose puisque vous êtes vous
voulez me poussé dans mes derniers autre
chose dans cet ouvrage il y a des
quantités de statistiques faites par des
bureaux d'études
il ya des statistiques sur la population
des statistiques
il y a également des sous l'état de
formation sur l'état de chômage il ya
tout ça dans cette vache et a aussi des
idées à développer mais donc les lions
et il ya des résultats les gens peuvent
donc se trouver dans ceux ci des choses
à poursuivre des choses à faire
c'est ce ne n'est pas c'était pas ces
pannes bible ou la victoire politique
non pas contre l'afrique monture et oui
de toute façon je n'ai rien contre le
cap nord où c'est à l'heure actuelle cap
nord est le quatrième intercommunalités
à cames intercommunalités sont un
territoire si implosive malo ccnm carnon
intercommunalités evans est basé mon
propos caution l'intégralité en aucun
cas j'en avais le pouvoir de faire les
choses ramel vous arrêter à communalité
par conséquent cet ouvrage n'est pas un
ouvrage qui me lance dans aucune
politique c'est une
série de suggestions en vue de retourner
en politique quand même de grandes
maisons je suis tout le monde est en
politique et toute sa vie parce que dans
le fond même si vous n'êtes pas sur le
terrain à guerroyer
vous avez une idée sur ce que votre pays
et puis la politique c'est participer à
la vie de la cité hier lorsque vous
présenter ce livre vous avez quand même
dit que vous vous aspiriez quand même un
petit peu plus de sérénité un peu plus
de meilleurs être en colère mais
j'assume et non parce que vos mains
d'hervé on me piquer mais non mais non
et puis tout la moule et voulait faire
les gens ne pas m'aimer le nom ce cas on
va maintenant en monochromie si vous
avez évoqué cette cette rente et de la
voix féminine en politique
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les choses auraient pu être différentes
si vous aviez été un homme menant tous
les projets qui ont été blessées hier
soir et c'est certain parce qu'elle est
la vie associative est un refuge pour
les femmes
elle s'exprime là elles font ce que ce
qu'elle voit nécessaire elles savent ce
sont des mères de famille ce sont des
chefs de famille des fois ce sont des
gens est sweet ce sont des gens qui ont
une vision
les femmes peuvent faire des choses des
fois mieux que les hommes elles sont
désintéressés souvent personne pour
qu'une femme le fait de la politique
pour gagner sa vie c'est ça ça ajoute à
ce qu'elle fait et c'est ça a été mon
cas c'est à cela s'est ajoutée et en
même temps on a le souci de former par
conséquent je pense que nos hommes
devraient se tenir
solidaire est et avant c est voir le
pays dans sa globalité pour sortir un
plan et est alors attention quand vous
êtes une maison vous vous mettez là et
vous vous regardez sa constitution puis
vous cherchez des les éléments avaient
les les matériaux et ben c'est ça la
martinique a besoin d'un projet global
de have a besoin d'identification de
projets parcellaire selon françois au
nord au sud accédant et d'une mise en
route dans l'unité regardez les dernier
modules de le voir il ya se soucier des
paroles de césaire et c'est le voeu de
martin luther king jr rêve et de al
khadim guèye j'ai fait un songe de
demain nous aurons la liberté de mai
nous serons libres et domaines où ils
avanceront vous avez beaucoup d'énergie
madden devant maison c'est pas ça c'est
le ciel qui m'a comblé merci d'avoir su
se mettre avec nous dans son caddie au
rappel cet ouvrage à parcourir
c'est vraiment une tranche d'histoire du
nord de la porte de la martinique il
voit pour le nord le nord mon tiroir
la martinique est mon pays une façon de
pour vous de clamer votre amour pour ce
pays basque à saint bonnet
[Musique]